live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions in nashville tennessee this is
the ramsay show where america hangs out
to have a conversation about your money
your relationships your life your
friends everything
give us a shout triple eight eight two
five five two two five i'm john colony
joined here by best-selling author and
i'll run great human being rachel cruz
and we're taking your calls on life
money work everything triple eight eight
two five
five two two five let's go to william in
fort worth tejas what's up william
hey guys how are y'all we're good
brother what's up
so
my
i
i just uh last friday i saw a week ago
um
actually um quit my job because my wife
requested me too
and
we were having we're having this
discussion now of well what do we do
with our finances because
it seems like you should have had that
conversation before she told you to quit
why why did she tell you to quit your
job
i have
i have a real bad heart and i was
working in the heat and it was
getting to the point where i was passing
out at work
okay so she was right so her her impulse
was let's a go with don't die b let's
figure out money right
yes okay
[Laughter]
rachel is a wife she's like i'm gonna go
with that one okay so
hold on why did your wife have to save
your life
why didn't you come to this
determination on your own
because i'm one that won't stop if i'm
unless i'm told no
like
i i i will
i'll go until i
burn out
can we just die
can we just uh that's immature can we
can we decide we're going to be
different from this point forward
yes okay good so we got a wake-up call
so what's your question
how do i talk to my wife about our
finances because we have two accounts
she has her account i have my account
okay
none of them are tied together
and so
i
i mean i don't see what she's spending i
don't she doesn't see what i spend and
i've talked to her about it
previously and she's like well i don't
want you to be mad at me for what i what
i spend
but we're in this together
for sure for sure um
which is kind of a common thing that i
hear when couples don't have their money
together it's like well i don't want you
to see because i don't want i don't want
to get ragged on of like i go to target
and probably spend too much money and i
want you to see it and you know like
that that is a
normal discussion point that we hear
from people when their accounts are
separate and you're talking about
combining them so
i'm not saying that's right but that
that is a common phrase that we hear so
would she be correct would you get mad
at how she spends her money you think
no
i wonder why she thinks that you will
she's a school teacher and
she she told me right before i
um
the thursday before i i put my
my
resignation in
that
well this next check is the one i play
with
i said well what do you do with it she
said
well i don't pay any bills with it i
said okay so
yeah you have enough yeah i mean i mean
okay all your all your bills with one
check and you play with it yeah and
there's there's so there's so much here
william
can i tell you what i think william i
think she's
i think she acts more like your mom than
your wife
and yeah i think that she has had to
create a world where she makes sure that
she can eat and everybody there's a roof
and there's bills that are paid
because you're a guy that's just going
to put his head down and do whatever
he's going to do even if it's going to
kill him
is that fair
yeah and then finally she said hey how
about you don't die like you're getting
pretty close to the edge here
and this conversation sounds like it
starts with you coming home and saying
i've been real immature and i've been
thinking about me to the point that i'm
just going to work myself to death
because that's kind of what i think i'm
worth
and she looked at you finally as you
were heading off the edge and said hey i
think you're worth a little bit more
than that because you're my husband
and so
i want to enter into a world where we're
going to do this together and i've quit
my job i've said i i i tapped out right
there's no bravado
the in the jiu jitsu world there's an
old thing like you don't tap out you
just no true jiu-jitsu artists tap out
when they get caught right that's it's
so you can live to go another day and
that's what you've done here and you can
stand before your wife actually take a
knee before your wife and say
i've been immature the way i've lived
and we're going to have to start this
whole thing over build something new
i want to start by being all in together
on this deal and i'm not going to judge
your purchases i'm i'm going to choose
to go first too um will you do this with
me yeah and william i mean honestly from
what even john what you just said which
i think was so spot on of her having to
create this world
you know
within herself and her money
uh
with
with you and your decisions all that
right like y'all have just been playing
in all these separate um these separate
fields and so my prayer would be that
she longs
to do this with you that she longs for
unity not just in your money but in your
marriage and into other decisions in
life not just about money and so
honestly if i were your wife if my if i
was in that situation and my husband
came home
and apologized
and said i'm so sorry that this is how
we've been doing our life and i take and
i take responsibility for not engaging
you
when it comes to money making you feel
like you have to
um
keep stuff from me and
and and i don't want that anymore i want
our marriage to be
i want us to to be fully known to be
open and to know what is going on
because we're we're a team in this like
and in this life do you all have kids
no okay
and so if that you know becomes part of
the formula later in life for you guys
it's like you want you want your
marriage to be
to be so unified and that you know each
other so well
um that it just brings this level of joy
william that i think you guys have been
missing and again the money stuff is a
symptom of a lot more going on but i
think if you went to her and said i'm so
sorry i'm so sorry for how i've acted
i'm so sorry for x y and z and i want to
sit me and you together and agree and
agree on our money and work together as
a team i want to do this together
and
and you guys and tactically sitting
there and listing out a budget like hey
if you're wanting to spend money let's
look at where we're at let's
and i want to spend money so do how do
we do this you know do we each have our
personal line items in the budget uh
have money goals if you guys have debt
to say hey let's work to start paying
this off together like i want you guys
to start working in unison but i think
william a huge step a huge step would be
for you to go in and apologize hey
william
why do you think you're worth
nothing
i don't know um
i have a college degree but
i can't use it
it's i mean it's in business
administration i don't even know what
what your degree is yeah you're busy i
disagree with this statement you could
you've decided not to
and that's that's fine it's all well and
good
but there's something beneath this that
you think man i'm just worth putting my
head down and just going until until
this thing runs out of gas
and it took a woman who loves you to say
no no no no i need
you here's the deal william i'd really
love you to be able to look in the
mirror and say i'm worth being here
and i'm worth having a life full of joy
and i'm worth having a marriage full of
joy and hold on the line austin pickups
and i want to give you guys a year
subscription of ramsey plus for you guys
to do every dollar together and to go
through the videos of financial peace
university together and you guys start
over start from translate to starting
today yep and that starts with you
looking in the mirror saying i'm worth
starting over
all right we're with you man thanks for
the call
[Music]
look i love real estate and i want you
to have a house but i don't want a house
to have
you
that's why you need to get in touch with
churchill mortgage to make sure you do
this right these guys are awesome
they'll help you get on a smarter
mortgage plan because they're committed
to doing what's right for
you
that means they check in every year with
free consultations to help you stay on
the right plan they show you how to save
money and interest so you can build
wealth faster they walk you through the
total cost of your loan so you can make
the best choice basically they care
that's why we call them ramsey trusted
you can achieve debt-free home ownership
and churchill is here to help
go to their site
churchillmortgage.com ramsey to start
your approval or get more information
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
this is the ramsay show triple eight
eight two five
two
let's go out to caleb in los angeles
california what is up caleb
hey guys how you doing good my brother
what's up
so i'll get right to it the question is
um do i just need to somehow make a
copious amount of money to stay living
here
or
do i need to take my wife and five kids
and move away that was an excellent use
of the word copious
just to start the call uh give us some
more context man
sure yeah yeah so um
you know nose to the grindstone through
baby step two like i'm sure most of your
listeners and
we look up one day we're debt-free
then we get pregnant with twins which is
still exciting um
and then so now we have five small
children under six and i can finally
move on to baby step 3b and that's when
i you know can really look around i'm
like oh my gosh
these starter homes are 850 000
and you've got five kids you got a house
full of you got seven people
yes yes there are seven
um yeah so there's seven of us and we
home school um i'm in the i'm in the
film industry but i don't have to be
here i'm a producer director so i can
travel around and i own a podcast uh
business but
um my income is probably like this year
i'll probably close out right around 140
000 before taxes but it's not always
like that you know it's up and down
entrepreneur so
yeah guys i mean i don't know what to do
like do i just hightail it out of here
or you know i don't i have no idea what
to do i just i've literally never been
this just
no clue what to
do and the main the the main motivation
to move is just is financial would that
be
number one for sure really the only big
reason or is there any other motivating
factors that you're like man we kind of
do want we're we're kind of feeling like
we want we want to change yeah so like
when i left when i left texas
money was definitely of a factor right
can i can i get
get a promotion can i get a different
job can i make more money
but the broader conversation with me and
my wife and and ultimately for our kids
was we want a different life i want my
kids to run around in the creeks and in
the trees and
i we want to have a different life than
was available to us where we were and
that was the ultimate
are we going to leave here the money
definitely played into that but it was a
life question so
yeah i would ask you do you love your
life there in california and do you love
the life of los angeles and you guess
you got you know 15 kids that you're
raising down there do you like that
or are y'all looking for because this
sounds like it's an existential question
right this is a different
you've reached the question that so many
filmmaker buddies of mine reach or
artists of mine say like
all right am i gonna go all in on this i
got five kids can i earn a living all
those questions right um so what's the
main motivation behind this question
uh yeah i think it's that um
i mean you guys have had hundreds of
callers complaining about california so
i'll spare you the
political rant but just insert that
right here and then in addition um i we
actually live about an hour north in
ventura so it's like a beach town 70
degrees every single day but i mean yeah
it's paradise but all of our friends are
dual income you know working constantly
you know yeah so i'm looking at my kids
and their kids i'm totally not
what's the legacy like are they gonna be
able to afford a home
um i definitely can i mean look god can
do anything right so of course i could
make more money and i could make you
know i could do the plan
but on the forecast right now it's just
not there to answer your question dr
john um
yeah i would love to
like we could do that legacy elsewhere
seems easier and i just cannot get a
home
with the with the current plan now so
yeah we're we're up to moving um so we'd
have to say goodbye to the perfect
weather but yeah and hey make no mistake
i was in um doing some media in
hollywood a few months ago
and i just well i i just started
laughing i walked out of my hotel that
morning and i was like oh this is why
everybody moves here it was magic right
the weather was perfect people were so
kind like i get that
and that was a snapshot that was a two
those are two days i was there i didn't
have to deal with the traffic or the
politics or the drama um a cool thing
about living in texas or tennessee and
other a couple other states is there's
no such thing as state income tax rate
so there's a whole bunch of other
factors there
um
but yeah there's a reason why rachel and
i are have a bunch of new neighbors from
los angeles and new york yeah cause i'm
moving my neighborhood caleb
california
and i live in the woods and my neighbors
are from california so yeah
it's but
there's a and there's a math not that
math has to be the
the director of your life right it's not
the number one factor of your life but
looking at the math it's like you you
know the cost of living where things are
higher and it's going to be higher where
you are and so there's a point where
it's like okay i'm looking at my income
i'm looking at our expenses and i'm
looking at what we want or what we value
as a family what we want for our family
long term and it just ends up easier if
your standard your cost of living
goes down because of when you move and
so that creates margin it creates
options and so um it's a very it's a
very real thing um to be able to say wow
we could move somewhere
get a house that actually will fit all
of our 18 kids and and our family and
enjoy
uh i actually can make decent money
still and i'm gonna have more that we're
gonna have as a family to to use whether
that's for investing or saving or giving
or spending um so yeah i mean there's a
true math equation there that you just
end up better
when you're not living in these high
cost of living areas it just is what it
is and so for you guys if you just got
to a point where you're just sick of it
and you're like it's just
we're done
um here's how we did this
psychologically in my house caleb
yeah because my wife and i had lived in
texas every day of our life
and so leaving this was a cultural move
for us it was an environmental move for
us it was it had a bunch of different
factors
um we sat down and said let's make a
three year commitment
and we know that the first six months
we're going to be lonely and it's going
to be wild and i got a new job and i
don't even know how the dmv works here
and there's different laws different
rules everything's different and so
we're going to we're going to commit
through that this idea that if we leave
we can never go back to california it's
a great point it's not true you can you
can move everybody back and you ought to
have y'all figure it out because you're
smart and scrappy and good and you know
what you're doing
and so i i would say hey let's make a 36
month commitment let's pick a place
whether it's north carolina or texas or
any who know anywhere kansas go to
kansas man kent is beautiful
go somewhere where you're going to have
the life that you want and it's going to
allow you so much more financial
flexibility than what you're dealing
with right now and still continue to be
able to create and do film and produce
and direct and do all those things that
you love to do um yeah it sounds like in
your heart you're gone now you're just
dealing with the angst of i made a hard
decision and now what do we do now yeah
right absolutely
all right it's still good oh you're
about to say well it's just like it's i
mean it's tough caleb because it's like
you know especially after you're a
parent you're like okay i'm making
decisions not just for me and after
you're married it's your spouse and then
once you have little ones that you're
responsible for it's like all right i'm
making it's a big deal there's a weight
to it so i so appreciate his like
hesitation and really and really
thinking through it but um but i also
think there's a reality to
to the math and
and the value of living that you want
with your family so and this always
brings to mind an important um i i heard
this from a counselor friend of mine in
relation to
breakups
but i think it applies all across the
board this idea that just because it
hurts just because it's uncomfortable
just because you get sad because you're
grieving doesn't mean it's not the right
decision
right and people would break up and
think i'm hurting so bad two days after
we've been married or not married we've
been dating for two years or we've been
married for a long time and we divorced
and it hurt so bad i must have made a
mistake and i was like no you made the
right call hurting is part of this
process so leaving the city where all
five of your kids were born leaving the
adventure and all the excitement that is
la
that's going to be a bummer right
believing that total weather that
incredible weather um there's a cool
thing that happens in tennessee that
doesn't happen in los angeles and it's
water falls from the sky several times a
week it's so crazy um they call it rain
and it's amazing and it fills up in
these uh basins called lakes it's crazy
four seasons yeah you get all four you
know that's why so yeah it's great caleb
give it a shot man give it a shot
um and okay sorry i know we're we're
we're continuing on this but again but
also on the total flip side of this i've
always answered this we had a debt-free
scream last week with the failing from
california they paid off their mortgage
and they're like they figured it out and
they were like you know math does apply
in california because it's always our
joke here that everyone's like well i
can't do that because i'm from
california uh and they did it and they
paid off their house and all of it so
will it take a longer time you get less
house for more i mean all of that yes
but you still can own a home in
california absolutely or caleb maybe you
quit doing indie stuff and you start
shooting features and you get into that
world and you get a more money make more
money and say this is just the life
so if you made more money caleb would
that change the conversation oh yeah so
if somebody just dropped 300 000 on you
would you move would you move or would
you stay
is that a fair question
i don't know
we'll be right back
[Music]
chaos
that's what it can feel like when your
business is growing so fast you've
outgrown your financial and accounting
software
the faster you grow the more likely you
are to lose control of the numbers and
here's the reality if you don't know
your numbers you don't know your
business that's why we use netsuite by
oracle the number one cloud financial
system over 28 000 companies use
netsuite by oracle including ramsey
solutions because netsuite gives us a
single view of everything we need to
make daily decisions whether you're
making a few million to hundreds of
millions a year netsuite gives you the
visibility and control of the things you
need to grow like your financials
inventory hr planning budgeting and more
all in one dashboard go to netsuite.com
ramsey right now to get their free white
paper jumpstart your cfo career
[Music]
triple eight eight two five five two two
five this is the ramsay show listen
every time you hear someone do their
debt-free scream on the show it's
because at some point they said enough
i'm not living like this anymore i've
had it
and when you get mad like that and do
what they did your life will change too
and right now inflation and your
ridiculous credit cards are killing you
you started to believe you're not in
control of your money wrong
you have to decide to control what you
can control and that's you your thoughts
and your actions you have the power to
change your future we're one of the few
groups of people left in the world that
still believe that people can change and
financial peace university will show you
how this course will teach you the
proven step-by-step plan that's helped
nearly 10 million people beat debt
master budgeting and build wealth and
you can do it too
stop letting debt and money stress
control your life say enough and take
back your control start financial peace
university at ramseysolutions.com
enough
that's ramsay
solutions.com slash enough let's go out
to philip in oklahoma city what is let's
see where he is there is philip what's
up phillip
yeah hey how are you i'm outstanding my
brother how are you
i'm doing great excellent so what's up
man how can we help
all right so i'm definitely not the type
of person who likes being in bed at all
it's a icky nasty feeling for sure
and i was never in debt until i married
my beautiful wife who has some student
loans
and we'd both love to get rid of them
but i've tried a couple budgets in the
past and i can't seem to get it right
and stick to it because the cost
estimates i can't seem to nail down and
unexpected costs things along those
lines
so
my question is
what are some tips and advice
for budgeting and saving money on a
lower income
yeah that's a great question phillip
well we teach because there's different
ways to do a budget right there's like
the
um
what is it like the 60 40 rule or the
you know there's all these different
types so the one that we really
recommend using is the zero-based budget
and that's where the income for your
month because you're gonna budget
monthly
not not necessarily weekly or even you
know some people do a yearly budget but
once a month
and you have your income for that month
and then all of your expenses underneath
including giving and saving
and the goal is for that income minus
all of those expenses should equal zero
so that's a zero-based budget and so
sitting down and doing that
you know for realizing a couple of
things uh having a miscellaneous
category is huge and it sounds like
that's one of the issues that you have
when something comes up you're like oh
my gosh we didn't plan for this
um so making sure you have
kind of that catch-all category which
helps a ton so it doesn't throw your
entire budget off
i would also say to to make sure that
you know a good um
estimate of what you spend your money on
realistically to i think some people go
into budgeting and they think
okay i'm gonna cut back all this stuff
and i'm gonna have 75 dollars for food
for the month and it's like it's
probably not gonna work uh so really
making sure hey we know
what we need not to be we're not gonna
be extravagant with it but like we know
what we need um in categories like food
transportation
obviously your rent or your mortgage
that's a pretty standard one that you'll
know predictable month to month
but really testing those out and the
other thing philip is give it 90 days
you have to give yourself three months a
lot of people the first time they do it
uh the first month or second month it
doesn't work so they're done and you
really have to stay with it up to three
months because
things are going to change throughout
the month again you predict something in
one category it ends up being something
else you have to end up upping that
category lowering other categories all
of it so it does take some strategy and
being really really intentional but some
of those things will help i think again
doing the zero-based budget doing it
monthly before the month begins giving
yourself 90 days
and then the last thing to philip i
would say is to make sure you're
tracking your transactions because
people will set a budget
and then they that's it they just set it
and they just keep living their life and
it gets to the 12th of the month and
they're like oh my gosh i don't know how
much we have left for food um you know
or or whatever's left so making sure
that you're tracking that and every
dollar our app here at ramsey solutions
does that it connects to your bank
and so that's a great option if you want
to do that or if you want to keep up
with you know as you're
spending money through the month as well
but
those are those again high level but
really practical ways um
to to do the budget and then again it's
also sticking to it like having to say
this is how much we have for food and
it's reasonable we're not we're not
going you know
we're not starving ourselves but
but we have to stay and we have to stay
in this and that means making different
decisions as well and especially if you
have a lower income
having to to use that income and stretch
it as far as possible is really key and
then if you guys don't have any savings
then a thousand dollar emergency funds
uh is the very first thing you want to
do before you start paying off that debt
uh but that's uh
and that's where that savings line item
will be and then once you have that you
can take that out of the budget because
you're not gonna be saving for anything
else because you have your start
emergency fund and then anything extra
goes towards that debt to pay it off as
quickly as possible philip why do you
have a lower income
what do you do um
well i i work for coca-cola and
um
i i do merchandising and i stock and
order
coca-cola for stores
and it's it's about 35k a year
and
so it's it's enough
but
it's
it just seems like it's shrinking
because of inflation and things like
that no it doesn't seem like it is it
absolutely is
how old are you
i'm 22. okay that job that you're
working is is hard work isn't it
yeah it's very physical it's very
physical it's hard work um
with your work ethic um and you're
you're you don't have any fear of doing
hard work
i think you could go get involved in
some trades and
make fifty thousand dollars before the
next in 60 days and you can find another
job
making some money
do you believe that you can do that
um
yeah i'm i'm not sure
how many other options there are for me
but i do i do really love the job that i
do as well here's the deal
you can love it all day long but you
have a math problem
right
yeah
yeah is your wife work phillip
no she she's in full-time school and um
uh i think this is yeah this is her last
year and her scholarships will pay the
rest of the way through but but you're
22 and it might be that for two years
you do something that isn't your dream
job or isn't you know fulfilling all of
your hearts
it you know i don't know rainbows come
out of the sky when you wake up every
morning
but you have a math problem you're just
gonna put food on the table and you're
going to work really hard to get this
debt paid off so that when she gets out
of school y'all are ready to run and do
whatever it is y'all want to do should
be hard to pay off student loan debt
phillip on 35 000 it's just gonna take
you guys a long time so i don't know if
that's getting even a
side hustle changing your full-time
career for sure is an option right like
john is saying but then also i think
picking up other work again to get to be
aggressive
to pay the student loan off but i also
don't want you guys becoming debt-free
and still feeling like you're just
living like
paycheck to paycheck still just because
of
because of your salary yeah yeah what do
you want to do long term brother
well
um well as a as of right now i was
actually picturing
working my way up in
in
within the company
i have
i
i am making about 30 more money than i
was when i got hired three years ago
it's still not enough
i thought if i sing it you could hear it
that way it's still not enough
you could you could be making a hundred
percent more than you were making a two
days ago it's still 35 grand it's still
not enough to get you guys out of the
hole is there a is there a track though
that you're seeing philip that you know
okay in in 12 months it's going to be
more like is there a progression that's
going to happen though that you know
um
well i guess i can't say that for 100
sure but i know that since i'm being
paid hourly and i get an annual raise
like um over time i'll become more and
more expensive to the companies yeah
exactly and
i was just talking to my friend ken
coleman and businesses are rolling
people back as they get more and more
expensive businesses are cutting
employees um
take a hard look at the mirror brother
and decide you're worth more than
your hourly rate right now and just
throw a line in the water and see my
guess is you can make 10 or 15
000
more
in short
[Music]
amazing
[Music]
so
[Music]
this is the ramsay show i'm john delonie
joined by best-selling author rachel
cruz and we're taking your calls on life
and money triple eight eight two five
five two two five let's go out to
michael
in denver what's up michael
how you doing dr john and rachel we're
good we're good what's up man how can we
help
uh calling today to see some advice um
i'm on
baby step seven
nice congratulations
thank you
so i'm debt free and i own my home
and my girlfriend and i are considering
taking the next step in our relationship
and
i would like to rent out my home
move in with her
for a short time to
build up some
more money and then she would be selling
her home and we would purchase a home
together
and
i'm not sure if that would be the right
thing to do um
a lot of the
things say yes as my home is paid off
and
would generate a very healthy
passive income
um to pretty much
pretty much cash flow the
the new home
um
with the sale of her house and the
purchase in the house that we would buy
together
so i have several thoughts across the
board you want all of them or just you
want me to answer your money question
uh
sure you give me all of them
all right
um
so
let me address it this way the research
is pretty clear
that
the
the relational satisfaction of people
who move in together who are not married
versus those who are and i know it's
going to get me the mean cards and
letters on the internet that's fine
it's just non-partisan data that says
every single factor in the relationship
um
you can just go down the list
every single factor is different it is
improved when you're married versus
moving in
um so when somebody asks me that
um yes i go to church there's there's
that but this is simply i just am
looking at the data and the chances of
your relationship being less
structurally sound
right
that's number one number two
when you buy a home with somebody you're
not married with you're in a you're
creating a business partnership
and
whenever you create a business
partnership part of the partnership is
always what happens if this business
partnership dissolves and if you are
dating
untangling that becomes a mess
if you are married and you get divorced
and i'm not saying that's going to
happen i'm just putting it out there
there is a there is a plan to follow to
divide this stuff up
so what i'm saying is if you are
moving into this house and you're going
to buy another house here and y'all are
going to share an asset over here that's
supposedly income generate all that all
that
it's it sounds like instagram math is
what i call it it's like if i do this
and i move this and i get some bitcoin
what i'm telling you is the chances that
some that the the train gets off the
tracks are greater
and it's infinitely messier
right so let me back up and ask you this
what's your long-term play here
i learn our long-term play is obviously
to create a life together um
i would by getting married first
yes getting married how long have i been
together
um about a year okay
all right she was previously married
before um has two children
um was married for eight years i think
one of her biggest concerns is is just
making sure that we are um you know
going about this the right way
and um you know obviously like this is
this is going to be um this is going to
be long term so and i would tell you i
would tell you the common fallacy is um
and it's it's it makes perfect logical
sense theoretically it just doesn't play
out in real life is that we're gonna
practice
you move in with me and my two kids
while i'm healing from divorce we've
been together a year let's practice what
it would look like if we were actually
doing this long term and make sure we're
all good and i get the theory behind
that it makes sense
um it also doesn't work in the data
okay okay it's it
rachel and i will tell you marriage
works when you both have jumped
and it's like we have to do this
together or we both hit the ground right
and that's that's the way marriage works
yeah there's a there you know you can
like you're saying you can try to say
okay yeah let's see because i just like
want to know like
does this does she hate the way i brush
my teeth you know like whatever like
that like you hear all these like little
things about people and i'm like
none of that like most of the stuff that
may bother you
that could be like um this is a sign we
shouldn't stuff that that's stuff that
doesn't matter in marriage it doesn't
and so there's a point that like there's
a relational thing michael here that is
really big really big that again i know
the culture and the world and everyone's
like oh yeah that's like what you do
it's the next step in a relationship is
to move in together
and so
what we found time and time again is
like it's for the best of both of you to
come together is to say hey we're going
to be in a committed
relationship and actually get married
before we make that step um we're going
to go all in on this thing the other
side of that is i i wouldn't and rachel
hop in here i would not
leverage my paid for house
um and then go
rent over here and then go take out a
mortgage and build something new it it's
getting so complicated so complicated so
michael if i were you if i woke up in
your shoes you're on baby step seven you
have paid for house you're dating a
wonderful woman
and you guys have been together for a
year
and i would say okay if you think that
this is long term then like all right
let's actually plan and let's just
pretend this is all pretend but let's
say
i'm gonna propose in six months we're
gonna get married this time next year we
have another year and she's gonna you
know she's gonna save i'm gonna save a
ton
and once we get married i'm gonna sell
my house she can sell hers we're gonna
put the money together and you start off
a marriage on a completely emotional
clean slate by doing the steps the right
way in that sense but then also
you guys financially could be going it
could be it could be amazing like you
guys could pay cash for a house together
and start your life off and that's the
number one stressor amazing the number
one stressor for new relationships is
money and you would take that off the
table
right right by choosing to get a
mortgage and to be a landlord on day one
is choosing to like hey let's opt in for
more stress and it already
bonkers
you know seasonable that's one of the
things i went back to on fpu is just
what rachel said and um
i mean yeah i mean
i that's the number one thing that i
would like to see for our future is
financial stability and
no money stress and yeah before house
and michael if you want a ranking two
good incomes it would be it would be
amazing yeah and michael if you want i
mean and and i come from a real estate
family my husband works in real estate
my dad loves real estate every like real
estate is like it's a it's a big deal
my family loves it so i love the idea of
passive income
uh of having another property so even
you yourself not with her until you're
married but if you're making a great
income and you have no debt you could
save up and go you know buy a condo with
cash rent it out kind of scratch the
itch and kind of figure out you know do
i want to do this real estate thing do i
want to invest in real estate is this
kind of the plan i want to go all with
cash but you can you can still choose to
go down that road it's not a it's not a
this or that kind of thing too so
um there's some numbers to play with and
and all that but yeah john and i
for the best interest of your
relationship and your money i would not
move in
and i would not try to rent out your
house when it's paid paid off and all of
that so
michael i'm going to say this is pretty
direct and i may even be overstepping my
bounds is that okay
sure
don't be somebody's tryout
don't leave your paid for home and a in
a pretty extraordinary life you've
you've lived to go see if you cut it
you're worth more than that
and she is too
okay sure
um and again i it's not a knock on her
if i'm her i would be terrified to do
this again because i've done it before
right and it painfully it hurt for me it
hurt the kids heard it was made a mess
so i get the hesitation i 100 get that
right but when we're both ready to jump
let's both be ready to jump not hey you
jump and let me know how deep that water
is
right and so that's just hey if you and
me were just having um grabbing a drink
and having some nachos i would take this
is just me talking to you this way okay
sure um
and rachel and i both just have
the both the fortune and the misfortune
of talking to countless people
who thought they were going to buck the
buck the data and it was like yeah but
we're going to be dif and it just ends
up in a mess right it just ends up in a
mess hey we're rooting for you
congratulations on clearly you're
brilliant and clear
of integrity well done um
best of luck to you and your new family
it's gonna be awesome
hey that's an hour in the books and
we'll be back soon right here on the
ramsay show
[Music]
hey it's john deloney co-host of the
ramsay show did you know over 18 million
people listen to the ramsay show every
week a lot of those people listen on one
of our 600 plus radio stations across
the country to find a station near you
go to ramseysolutions.com
[Music]
bye
[Music]
live from the headquarters in nashville
tennessee this is
the ramsey show where we talk about your
life and your money
and your relationships your friendships
and here's the best part
we talk with you all right so give us a
call at
825-5225 i'm john dalony joined here by
my good friend rachel cruz best-selling
author all-around good person and we are
taking your calls on pretty much
everything
what did i do
i need that pin over there oh i took
your pen rachel i'm sorry i just look
right i don't know how to sli how to say
that like
incognito but i need a pen no i'm not
great at it because when numbers happen
i gotta write them down there you go
eight eight two five five two two five
let's go out to elijah in boise idaho
what's up elijah
hi thanks for having me on hey my
question is so i'm going through a
divorce currently
so sorry yeah
um but i own a house and i have quite a
bit of equity in the house and she's
entitled to half and my question is
if i should sell it and just be done and
rent from there or
if i should
try to refinance my house and cash her
out and keep keep the house
okay so how much is the house worth
so the house is worth around
uh 250 000. okay and how much do you owe
on it
i owe 120 currently 120 okay
um
i wouldn't go
i wouldn't go into debt to pay your wife
off
okay so adding the right to the mortgage
yeah yeah i'd sell the house sell the
house split the equity and
um
yeah it kind of feels like the cleanest
yeah scenario yeah help me with this
rachel because and uh elijah i'm gonna
think about this out loud what i'm
thinking of is um two years from now
you're still paying on this divorce
right right because you're still paying
and five years from now seven years from
now you're still paying
on this loan you took out against your
home to pay your wife off
right
i would rather with the end of the
divorce be done with my
relationship here and move on
right
well kind of what i'm looking at because
in the boise area housing prices are
astronomical and even with the amount
that i'd get from the sale
i don't it wouldn't be enough to put
down on anything that would be suitable
and within my price range
no no i'm looking to rent everything in
your in your life has exploded no
question yeah
things that it gets people into trouble
when they head into
um a situation where everything's blown
up and they pretend part of it hasn't
right right like so imagine your house
burned down and you just went to get
some fast food and you sat down at your
old dining room table that's basically
ash
right
i'm just gonna pretend this thing's not
like man everything's over so yes it's
expensive to live where you live
um and yes you're gonna have to change
your style of living and what's what
wasn't acceptable might have to be
acceptable for a season while you get
your feet underneath you or you may have
to rent even though you didn't imagine
yourself renting in this season of life
but man yeah i i would i would sell it
and then within the equity you guys when
you get out of the house
you know obviously 50 50. and i'd give
yourself a year give yourself a year i
think rent somewhere
um and you'll get 65 65k out of it so
it's that's a great down payment for
something um but i wouldn't even i
wouldn't rush into a new house even i i
would as john would say you know grieve
what you're going through
um
sit and and be sad and i mean everything
that that a divorce comes because it's
really heavy it's really really heavy um
and be in that and give yourself give
some time to heal before making any
huge money decisions and buying a house
would be considered a huge money
decision so i would i would rent 12
months
um yeah my mentor dr andy young is
he says don't make any major decisions
for six to six to 12 months yeah yeah
just don't don't buy anything don't quit
anything don't run from anything do you
have kids
yeah i have two kids two kids okay
um how old are they
uh two and three what's the custody
arrangement
um currently i'm kind of going through
that but right now it looks like it'll
just be 50 50. okay
yeah it's going to be a mess
it's going to be hard across the board
and so i i
yeah i'm with rachel i would rent the
house and
and stay put for a while
okay no i really appreciate that thank
you you bet yep uh
that's hard so sorry i'm sorry my
brother yeah all right let's go out to
leslie in mason city what is up leslie
yes got a question for you i am going to
be 44 this fall and recently divorced i
am currently renting i'm on baby step 3b
wanting to know if i should continue
i want to pay cash for house so if i
should continue just saving everything
for the house
or should i at some point
start investing
i just don't know what to do yeah
uh how much do you have left to save if
you were to pay cash for a house
um so i just moved into a new apartment
so i'm now able to start saving 1700 a
month oh way to go
yeah
how much do you have how much i want now
i have nothing saved right now okay i'm
just starting yeah i have to rebuild my
emergency fund okay i got you and i just
finished doing that oh good okay well
well done that's that's amazing thank
you and you said recently divorce so
you've gone through you know even the
last caller we were talking about um
a really really hard thing and now
you're
finding stability and you got your
emergency fund all of it so that's
incredible so congratulations
um thank you
you know paying and i want to have a pay
for house i'm 50. so i got like six
years yes yes okay so here's the deal
though if you're saving up to pay cash
for a house i would still invest so i
would if i were you
i would say okay how much is it going to
take to have a down payment
on a home because that's baby step 3b
you know like we talk about so finding
that down payment range saving that
amount pressing pause or pressing play
back on investing because i still want
you to invest especially you know at
your age um so saving up a down payment
then pressing play on investing and then
look to see where you're at leslie
because
i mean we're okay debt you know
obviously 100 down is like amazing and
it's what we would hope for everyone and
we think it's great because we hate debt
but a mortgage is the one type of debt
we would not yell at you for so if you
did
have a great down payment and there was
something you loved like we wouldn't be
mad at you for for just doing that too
right to get into the house and then
paying it off quickly but if you really
are gung-ho and you're like i want zero
debt um then i would save up that down
payment
again start investing after that saved
and then
just keep saving on top of that until
you can cashflow home if that's what you
decide leslie why do you why do you want
to why are you adamant about paying cash
i don't ever want to go back to debt i
paid off my debt um
18 months ago
and i don't ever want to go back into
that again good for you and the houses
where i live i can actually find there's
plenty of houses for less than a hundred
thousand it's actually like super cheap
to live where i live awesome awesome i
just want something tiny it's just me
yes that's great well
and if you can you know whatever the
math ends up being
down the line i mean if you're
saving for two three years you could
just do that and then if that's enough
to pay cash uh but i would i would start
investing though that's usually the rule
of thumb if it's if you could think you
can do it in two or three years yep head
down do it yeah that's right but it's
gonna be five or six i wouldn't go
longer than three years without
investing yeah you don't want to look up
at 50 and have you paid for house and
zero in retirement that's gonna be a
scary proposition great job leslie
though great job congratulations we'll
be right back
[Music]
life is full of firsts
[Music]
as the first and longest serving
christian health cost sharing ministry
chm has shared medical expenses for its
members since 1981
we believe you should have the freedom
to focus on your health while being
supported by a community of believers
giving you the opportunity to create
many more firsts
[Music]
blinds.com's 100 satisfaction guarantee
means even if you mismeasure or pick the
wrong color they'll remake your blinds
for free you get free samples free
shipping and with the new promos they
run every month you'll save even more
use promo code ramsey to get the best
deal rules and restrictions apply
today's question comes from amelia in
colorado my husband and i have been
saving for a house since we got married
18 months ago i need a little direction
as we planned for a family i'd like to
stay home with them
and go to being self-employed part-time
should we base our home purchase
around our current dual income and pay
it down as quickly as possible refine
when kids arrive or
should we rent a few more years and buy
something we can afford on my husband's
income knowing that i will stop working
when we have children even though we
don't have a timeline for that yet
okay
um amelia i would
i mean it depends on when you want to
have kids i don't think you said that in
the question i'm really looking at it
but yeah i mean if you if you're gonna
have kids in less than three years
then i would rent
save up uh down payments and buy based
on just your husband's income
but if you guys are going to wait five
years or more to have kids
then i would
uh
i would save
up a down payment
and then do like i would do probably
like a split because by the time in five
years your husband's income should be
going up
but i would do it where it's still that
kind of 25 30 percent of your take-home
pay
yeah i
here's the question i would ask me so
one thing i think this is good advice
for all families if you ever back
yourself into a corner between an either
or decision i would stop the decision
making process and give it 30 days and
just chill because there's always dif
there's always more variables than just
this one or that one right and you've
you've backed yourself into do we buy a
huge house with dual incomes and try to
pay it down and refi and put all these
variables out here or
do we just live in a tent and we're just
gonna you know plug along to it doesn't
have to be either or
um and there's also rachel i mean my
wife and i we had some
we're gonna start having kids and it was
looked up and it was three or four years
later i was gonna say it was three or
four years later
before you know or five or six hours a
million years till josephine came along
so yeah um we have all the plans in the
world and who knows and you might get
pregnant the first week you know you
might get pregnant next week so
i love to loot back and ask yourself why
would you need a
house for just two of you
that you're gonna max out your dual
income purchasing capacity like you
don't need a house like that
get a one bedroom apartment enjoy your
life or get a small right so let's
reimagine what we're even doing here and
why we're doing it and what we
want versus what we actually need yes
yes and let's i don't know i like
playing a long-term game here
but that's just me it's good no i think
so too yeah all right let's go to mike
in richmond virginia what's up mike
hey how you doing outstanding brother
how are you
i'm good excellent what's up
um so basically uh i'd like to just some
advice on how i should be managing my
money um coming into a
big uh
paycheck you know income change uh with
my new job and um
just how i should be
managing it
that's a great question what are you
making now what will you make
i'm sorry what was that
how much money is a big raise how much
do you make now versus what are you
gonna be making
so
uh um 71 000 base uh raise is 15 so
that's
uh ten thousand six hundred
and then i'm getting a thousand dollars
a month per day um
i also don't have a
a lease or a mortgage um
living at the job site uh the hotel
country club
thing so i'm living there
no food expenses either i get vouchers
for food
i also get paid to drive home
every weekend
to my dad's house um
so basically uh uh monthly income
uh for the next year and a half from
looking at 9 200
a month yeah and you i was going to ask
you what's when does this job finish
uh a year and a half from now okay so
this isn't a long term raise for the
rest of your life this is a single
project where you it's a pretty cool
setup for the next 18 months
yeah um but the thing is i could i'm in
filming construction management so uh
you know after this one's done i could
sign up for the next out of town job and
get the same deal
right unless construction comes to a
halt right and here's what i'm saying um
rachel's gonna walk you through the
budget and like where you should be
financially but when you're working job
to job like this
assuming this is just gonna continue for
the rest of your life is how people end
up buying a hundred thousand
trucks and getting them all jacked up
and getting campers and things like you
see what i'm saying it's easy to get way
ahead of yourself and i got buddies on
construction sites and oil field sites
that have a lot of cool toys and then
suddenly they don't have any work
right yeah no i uh there's a lot of
stuff coming down the pipe that will
keep my company pretty busy so um
i see you know don't see an issue with
uh work coming anytime soon uh do what
kind of debts do you have mike
uh zero i'm very fortunate um parents
you know put together college savings so
zero there um truck is
owned uh my dad
uh
fortunate my dad purchased it for me
while i was in college
um that's great how old are you no debt
at all
23. 23. okay great job
incredible um
are you are you saving any money for
retirement are you investing anything
right now
yeah um 20
uh total
into a 401k
um and so 20 into the 401k and then or
sorry 10 into the 401k and then 10 into
the roth nice
um
that's great are you maxing out your
roth
i believe so yes okay um i believe so
yes because it'll be around my company
also is um putting in
uh eight percent i think
into that into your roth ira or your
401k is it the match i believe it's the
401k yeah dollar for dollar yeah i mean
after it's weird the way they do it but
it's uh eight percent dollar for dollar
basically okay
um gosh michael i mean i mean fantastic
job fantastic job so um
yeah so if i woke up in your shoes i say
around the shop but i'm like if i woke
up in your shoes
you're single young got a great job no
debt you're funding retirement and
you're doing exactly what you should be
doing so really
when it comes down to it there's three
really basic things you do with money
you can give it you can save it and you
can spend it and so i would allocate
percentages now on your paycheck for
what you're doing so you have that 20
retirement you could back down that down
to 15 you know you recommend 15 that'd
be plenty
um which would free up some more cash
for you throughout the month especially
with an eight percent match right yes
yep and then i would um
i would be i would be giving some and
then i would just i would look long term
too to think okay where do i want to be
in the next five years because because
you can enjoy some of this right
spending is part of the equation um but
i mean i would love for you to own a
home at some point i don't think it's
needed right this minute but um
but i think homeownership is it's just a
good investment long term and so if
there's something that you see down the
line in the next you know four or five
years who knows well you'll be with your
job and life and everything but if you
just had some money
set aside um that you were just
stockpiling for the next big transition
again whether that's marriage or
changing jobs or whatever it may be
is just gonna help you so i would um
really control your spending you have
you have a great income again to be able
to enjoy life so i want you to enjoy
some of it uh because i think that
you're just in a great spot but i would
just be really
um
specific with my percentages i would say
i'm going to be giving
you know
10 15 20 i'm going to be investing 15
i'm going to save extra just for like a
future funds you know with another 10 15
i'm going to spend this amount like i
mean i would just be really specific
because you don't need a lot to spend
because your basics are covered but
um but have some permission to say hey
you can enjoy life but i would assign
percentages mike if i were you and mike
let me tell you this
um
this is just gonna sound like i'm a guy
who's
walking up hill
in the snow on the way to school right
almost like an old man
in the construction business there will
be a season when the slow is way way
down for you and you're 22 or 23 and you
don't see it yet it will come and
there's gonna be somebody that you meet
you want to get married and doesn't want
you on the road for the rest of your
life so rachel's wisdom is so wise
why don't you decide at 30 i want to
paid for a house in cash i want to do
that so i'm going to start putting money
away in an account and hold on to it
and live as frugally as possible because
there's going to come a rainy day and
there's going to come some excitement
that i don't even know is on its way
right
[Music]
if you're looking for ways to update
your home without blowing the budget
i've got it for years i've been telling
you about our friends at blinds.com
blinds.com makes it simple to shop top
quality blinds shades and interior
shutters from home with easy online
ordering and free shipping with
blinds.com there's no need to renovate
your entire home just change out what's
on your windows with upscale choices
like faux wood blinds cellular and
roller shades or even outdoor shades
plus blinds.com guarantees the perfect
fit whether you do it yourself or you
have them measure and install everything
for you shop their latest looks and see
how much you can save at blinds.com
today the easy and affordable way to
make your home more beautiful is
blinds.com
[Music]
this is the ramsey show triple eight
eight two five five two two five and
we have two wonderful people on the debt
free stage jordan and rachel so i'm
assuming you're here to do your debt
free scream yes we are fantastic so how
much have you paid off we have paid off
exactly ninety five thousand six hundred
and twenty nine dollars and fifty eight
cents wow amazing not that we're being
exact and where y'all in from
jamestown new york james awesome new
york how long did it take you 19 months
whoo y'all were cooking oh yeah what was
your salary here uh we started off at 84
000 and went up to 110 000. nice what do
y'all do
um i'm a nurse okay and i work in the
office at a heating and air company okay
so great you guys congratulations thank
you so what happened 19 months ago that
that made you jump on board
we got married
there you go
so it actually started about four years
ago
when my parents wanted me to go to a fpu
class that our church was teaching
and i i had that mentality that prideful
mentality that i knew what i was doing
and i clearly didn't so it was a very
mind opening experience and then
about four lessons in or so that's when
i met rachel and we started dating and i
think about two months in i was i got
her going on a budget and was
questioning her like crazy so
so you jumped in hardcore you were like
i don't want to do this fpu thing and
then
you're like i'm i'm all in yeah yep and
uh yep that's basically how that works
so yeah yeah what was your
what was the date like when you're like
hi
um if this is going to go any further
you're going to do a budget pretty much
not the hottest way to introduce
yourself no i did it very subtly because
i didn't want to scare her off or
anything she introduced me very slowly
yeah
he brought he invited you over to watch
netflix and he's like i can't find it
how about we watch fpu videos yeah yeah
that's basically how that happens well
played my man
okay so you guys but you but you
it took you 19 months though but you
were saying four years ago so what
happened in between all of that you guys
start dating
you get married and then you say okay
we're gonna hit this debt yeah basically
after we got married so um i i when we
looked at rachel's budget um
all of that was her student loans and
that's when i that's when we kind of had
a game plan and uh well we got when we
got engaged then
we also had to cash flow our wedding so
we had a pretty good sized wedding that
we cash flowed and then we said right
after that we're just going to go crazy
on the debt so okay so all 95 was from
from the nurse
very grateful to
find somebody who was like you know what
yeah you have all of this debt it's now
going to be my debt too so to have
someone to like really work with me and
you know take care of me yeah it was
amazing so it was my debt but jordan's
my partner and he really helped me so
can i ask you a hard question there oh
sure i hear this often um especially
when we're off air that when
when a couple is paying off debt
especially a newlywed couple they're
paying off debt and most of it or all of
it is
one of yours
that it's easy for you to feel
seven months in that
that blanket of shame just starts to sit
on you like it's my fault we're not
going on vacations if it wasn't for me
he would be able to
and it's easy on the other side
to start slipping into the ash of
resentment right like man good grief
could i i make a great salary it'd be so
cool to have a real car that i'd have to
start with a rope right so how did you
all manage that
oh that's a really good question and i
would say that there has been times that
we
you know
me especially i was like man i really
should be
picking up even more shifts at the
hospital like pulling more of the weight
just because it's all of the debt is
mine um i all i can say is jordan's like
100
in
to like the ramsey steps and he was just
like the best supporter in it so i
really don't know how to answer your
question because he's one of a kind
[Laughter]
no but i think you guys chose early on
even you know you chose early on that to
be unified in it
and it kind of you share the weight in
it even though what john said totally
happens right for a lot of couples those
emotions and all of that can play in
because we hear it all the time too uh
but there is something beautiful about
both just going 100 in so people
listening to right now to this call and
they're thinking oh man like you know i
have all this debt and i i'm fearful
that my you know my husband's gonna
resent me or all this right but there's
something to be said with you guys that
yeah but when you go 100
and together there's such a stronger
uh more motivating factor that happens
absolutely because it lifts some of that
weight off your shoulders and it's not
on yours so what encouragement would you
give people listening that think oh i
have 95 000 student loan debt we're
young you know we're newlyweds as well
there's no way we can do it what would
you say to them
um
it's not as bad as it always i think
it's not as bad as you think at first
because when we first sat down when we
got married i we looked at it and
our actual first projection was about
three years that it would take us and i
was kind of like rolling my eyes not in
a really good mood about it but
you just have to have that mentality of
like you just gotta push you gotta fight
with everything you got and
sacrifice too to say no to things to
like think about the end game like we
just it just made us want to work even
harder to pay it off even faster
um so yeah i just think not losing sight
of that so how did you all get from
three years to a year and a half how did
that when you did it when you said well
the next three years you guys did in 19
months how did you do that yeah um well
she's a nurse at a at a hospital and so
they were offering a lot of incentive
pay so she would take a lot of extra
shifts on
and she worked days and nights like two
weeks on two weeks off so it was very
sporadic and we didn't see each other a
whole lot but
it was worth it in the end and i did a
lot of i did a couple of odd jobs like i
did um i did a secret shopper job
and then i did car detailing on the side
my dad and i also rent a tent out so it
was just a lot of little things that i
did so that's just kept going yeah
that's so good so what would you say the
key to getting out of debt is
oh man i think just really just having a
budget i don't think we could have done
it at all without really organizing
where we're putting everything and
um you know like jordan said having that
projection it
really like puts things into perspective
so with the budget we were able to
project okay we're going to have this
much in this you know amount of time and
i really think i know everyone says the
budget but for us it i'd i'd be lost
without it yes it's the road map yes
yeah yeah i almost say the budget and
then also
i kind of had this thing i started
saying like ignore society and follow
the truth because
society kind of just tells you
everything wrong to do with your
finances and it's just it's it's kind of
it's almost it gets to me a lot because
i'm a little passionate about it so
i get a little upset but i just go back
on the truth and the truth hasn't let me
down so yeah just keep your passion you
had a you had a budget template in your
tinder profile man so yeah he's super
passionate about it for sure he has a
whole spreadsheet that's what we did for
like hours made a huge spreadsheet
actually i love that ignore society this
is like a good punk man name man yeah i
just love it i love it well hey we have
a copy of dave's best-selling book total
money makeover that you can take and
give to somebody we're also going to
give you a year of um the financial
piece right so you can you can hand that
off to somebody else and you that you
work with that you know and you think i
think it's time for them right we're
also gonna give you a copy of baby steps
millionaire because that is your
next step so we have jordan and rachel
from jamestown new york who paid off 95
629 dollars and 58 cents
in 19 months making 84 000 up to 110 000
nursing doing administrative work
cleaning cars moving tents whatever it
took to get this thing done in 19 months
we're so proud of you count it down
let's hear your debt free scream
three two one we're done
[Applause]
[Music]
i love it here's my favorite thing they
planned
the debt pay off they planned
they're debt-free screamed together
they've got the cash
that's so good so good congratulations
you guys america if you're listening
you can
too
we'll be right back
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
the last couple years in the real estate
market have been tough
we've all felt it home prices
skyrocketed in a way we haven't seen
before and interest rates are up and now
no one knows what's happening next or
how to handle it if you're scared you
don't have to be even though the market
seems crazy right now it's not going to
crash
if you're ready to buy or sell now's a
good time to do it all it takes is
navigating the market with knowledge and
skill
unless you're a rockstar real estate
agent yourself you need an agent who's
experienced in difficult markets and can
help you avoid costly mistakes one who's
at the top of the industry like one of
our endorsed local providers
these are top performing agents who are
experts in their local market have spent
multiple years in the industry and have
the transactions and success to back it
up they've earned the right to be called
ramsay trusted because we know they'll
serve you well and help you make
decisions based on facts and actual
experience you need the best of the best
when you're buying or selling a home
find a ramsey trusted agent by going to
ramseysolutions.com
agent that's ramsaysolutions.comagent
let's go to zach in huntsville what's up
zack
hey am i am i there yeah you're
here okay it blinked out for a second
what's up ma'am
not much uh talked to you and dave about
four months ago dealing with anger after
divorce i followed up with you and
george two months after that and now i'm
here for part three all right thank you
what's up may i'll give you the actual
real answer of life exactly you've
needed rachel this whole time man sorry
sorry zack haven't been there for you
but i'm here i'm just kidding i
appreciate that rachel john has given me
terrible advice right now
i think so i think so zach so what's up
i'm just kidding um
no so um
recently the loneliness has actually
just
gotten to a bad point because i
mentioned the other two times i drive
truck over the road
got to the point i made the really tough
decision i need to get out of this at
least for a season however
i had two things coming up that i got to
deal with first i got to get moved and i
found a couple options that will pay
decent but i also need to get my hazmat
tanker endorsements before i can
actually do those so i was seeing if you
have any advice to help deal with the
loneliness until i get out of this it's
gonna be about two to three months to
accomplish all of these things
i i think
people can do most of anything for two
or three months i mean you're talking 60
or 90 days is that to get your
endorsement and it's going to allow you
to to what what is that what are you
moving towards uh professionally
i'm gonna i'm gonna go haul a field
tanker and just uh build uh fill up a
gas uh deliver to gas stations because
it's home daily and i can
sorry mike huskies over here want to
talk to you guys um
yeah that'll allow me to go home daily
and
be around some friends and have a chance
to relax and get my head straight after
this divorce is over with okay so what
is this training what
what's your schedule going to look like
the next 60 90 days
um
staying on the road i'm gonna go home on
the weekend of the 17th next month for
my niece's birthday
and then
aside from that i don't know exactly how
often i'll go home i'm going to try to
stay out enough to
maximize the money that i need to get
moved
and then it costs about 61 to get the
hazmat endorsement i'm actually going to
do that on the same weekend as maybe
it's a birthday as long as i can get the
appointment set up at the dmv so let's
do this let's do this
um
let's put a big star on the calendar
for
um
75 days from now
and you're gonna that's the day after
you take your exams
and you're gonna invite people to your
house
and you're gonna have a good time
you're gonna celebrate people people are
going to celebrate you you're coming out
of a dark season man
the trucking almost kills you the
marriage mess the divorce all that
stuff's been just piling up and piling
up let this be a moment of celebration a
moment of
peace
right and then we're going to head into
some highly intentional i'm going to
choose to have people into my life and
for you who's been on the road for a
while it's going to feel awkward it's
going to feel weird and you're going to
feel stuck and it's gonna feel boring
and you're gonna have to practice having
people over in your life because you
know if you don't the end result's not
great right so we're gonna be
intentional about it but let's put a
star on the calendar and let's just run
hard for the next
60 75 days okay because when you put
that thing on the calendar and get it
ready your body can get there okay
your body can get there
i i like the idea of having a little bit
of celebration that actually might help
listen not a little bit
some not i don't want you to like have
two buddies over and you're all gonna
play dungeons and dragons and eat pizza
that's not what i'm talking about i'm
talking about
will over here in the booth he's like i
like dungeons and dragons
um
now i i want you to have a something
that your you and your body will look
forward to
a celebration of a new chapter in my
life
okay a big deal let's do something big
because you're going to shift everything
after this you're going to have to learn
new skills the skills of i come home
every day
and then i'm not going to sit down and
just let netflix run the next show and
the next show in the next series i'm
going to create a life worth living and
that's one where i get outside that's
when where i exercise that's when i hang
out with people that's one where i date
again it's one where me and my dog go
out and we go on adventures and we go on
hikes i'm gonna build a life
i'm not gonna just accept whatever life
i have left after i get done working a
job that i hate
see the difference
it
yeah yeah that's
honestly what i was aiming for that
it was kind of like the epiphany that
happened when i decided i need to get
out of otr i i won't admit i love my job
but i
but your job is all i know this might
just be a season where i'm out and then
i get back in it after things have
cooled off but i don't overthink it man
it got hard yeah and as excited as that
celebration is that star on the calendar
like john said
also take what he said and and put other
things on the calendar and say hey in
six months i want to take a road trip to
see a friend from high school that
hadn't seen him forever
uh where i'm gonna hike two
two days a week this week i'm gonna like
actually plan out because as attentional
we talk about uh with
as much as intentional as we talk about
money on this show and budgeting and all
that the same is true with your time and
if you're not careful zach that whole
idea of coming home netflix just go in
bed early just well you know you can get
back into another rut
even with your life change oh yeah man
so being intentional with your time to
zach is is huge uh for this next season
so go ahead and plan it out and just
have fun with it you know it's not it's
not a burden just say what are fun
things that i want to do that i've
wanted to do for a while and have been
able to and write them out and put them
on the calendar what she's talking about
is
let's budget for our life
not financially but let's build a
non-anxious life
let's build a life worth living right
and it's going to be step by step piece
by piece we're going to practice it and
it's going to be weird and awkward but
let's go do that is that cool
yeah yeah that's actually a good idea
that i didn't think about i know a
couple of things that i want to do in
the next little while but i
i think that might actually work because
like for example i want to go skiing
again i haven't been skiing since i was
eating put it on the calendar i'm trying
to do that for the
last you should have called rachel a
long time ago hey i could have given you
all this thought all these practices
john's over here just
just run hammer and hearing
all right zach so you're gonna call back
in february
okay
you're gonna call back in february when
i'm on when rachel's on and john on your
way home from your ski trip
okay
and you're gonna talk to us about
um being 60 days in
at home
you're going to talk about your workout
program you're going to talk about the
group of guys that you're hanging out
with whether y'all go throw darts once a
week or you'll all go mow each other's
lawns on the way i don't care what
you're doing we're going fishing or
hunting i don't care what it is
you're going to tell us about these
things that you are intentionally doing
to create a life worth living a life
full of joy
is that is that a deal i can do that
all right deal we'll be here
cool
cool all right man congratulations zach
yeah on your whole man see if everybody
in america knew just ask rachel
just asked rachel i should be on the
show dave doesn't know what he's talking
about i sure don't know what i'm talking
about can i
except for old rachel
no zach well hey everybody that's
another hour in the book i want to thank
kelly james ben zach andrew austin you
know what i'm gonna think kelly again
i'm even gonna think will
and i'm gonna thank you america thanks
for joining us we'll be right back this
is the ramsay show
[Music]
hey it's rachel cruz co-host on the
ramsay show if you want to do your debt
free stream live on the show visit
ramseysolutions.com
debt free screen we'd love for you to
come to nashville and tell dave your
story that's ramsey solutions.com
debt free screen
[Music]
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions this is the ramsey show where
america hangs out to have a conversation
about your money your life your
relationships your job pretty much
anything
here on the rapey show i'm john colony
joined by my good friend best-selling
author rachel cruz and we are taking
your calls at
825-5225 that's triple eight eight two
five
five
two two five let's go out to nicole in
new haven connecticut what's up nicole
hi can you hear me okay absolutely can
you hear us
yeah oh yeah definitely hi oh my god
it's such an honor to talk to you guys
the honor is all ours what's up called
yes
um so
um i'm having a little bit of analysis
paralysis when it comes to my side
hustle
i currently do massage therapy as a
full-time career and
that usually is about 35 hours of
massage
so
the thing with that is that i make about
50 to 75 an hour doing that
but i really do need another side gig
um and anything else
i start to feel like oh my gosh if i do
that job it takes me six or seven hours
to make what i would make in one massage
but i'm getting
incredibly burnt out
with my career that i decided was like a
passion and now it's become almost like
a burden
and i'm not really sure how to
go about a side hustle
does that make sense i don't know
no it totally does because you want to
be able to enjoy what you're doing and
still make great money because i'm like
you're like i don't want to sacrifice
the financial side
um but you also want to want to enjoy
what you're doing as well so is there
anything else on the horizon that you're
thinking of job-wise they're like man i
would love
to do this or that is there anything
specific
uh career-wise that you're passionate
about
i mean down the line yeah eventually i
would like to get into a more of a
counseling including massage type of um
like my own business but i need to
get myself out of debt before i do that
so um but like i've been looking at
other side hustles like um i mean to
silly but like pet washing you know you
can do that
but those things you know they don't
make a lot of money it's like 10 13 an
hour and it's uh it's like a love i
would love to do that as a side gig but
at the same time it's like oh
how much did you report how much of your
salary did you report last year nicole
um so i grossed 60 000. okay
how much did you have
i have about
65. okay what's your what was your net
take home
um so i pretty much take home about
19.50 every two weeks so almost 4 000 a
month
okay
um and i also do massage on the side for
my other job so that's my full-time job
so i have um another massage gig which i
thought was going to be my side hustle
but they're they're not consistent
enough so i know i need to get something
that i have to actually go to
and kind of clock in and do so that i
know that i'm definitely going to be
making
you know a set amount like whether it's
300 extra week or whatever so let me let
me post it to you this way and then i
know rachel's she's demonstrated in
earlier hours she's infinitely smarter
than me coming out with a path here
um so you've you've been around our gang
a little bit so you've you've heard
about gazelle intensity right
yeah
and the idea being
that gazelle is running
to not die right
that gazelle is running from a line
that's trying to kill it and eat it and
the gazelle is going to run maniacally
away from this thing
what that gazelle is not going to do
is go oh my gosh there's a lion
a cheetah all right or cheetah this path
is um
let's let's look for a smoother path
hang on cheetah hang on hang on hang on
um
let's look for okay this path was fast
ah for a minute but then i gotta go over
there and the grass is tall
the cheat the the the
that gazelle is just gonna run
right gail's gazelle's gonna run towards
a goal and the goal is not dying right
your goal is gonna be to get out of debt
so that you can actually get on with
your life doing what you really want to
do
and you can make real good money doing
it is that fair
that's completely fair so i feel like
i'm in quicksand yes so what if you put
a star on the calendar 24 months from
now and said i will have paid off all of
my debt by 24 months what do i have to
either a earn collectively
and you can do death by bb gun right 300
bucks here and 25 bucks here and 75
bucks here feels insulting until you
look up in a month and you've knocked
out 500 extra dollars
and then you've looked at right so it
starts to snowball in itself
or how what can i cut out of my life
that's really the only two things you
can do right but the goal here is i'm
going to be away from this cheetah i'm
going to be safe in 24 months
whatever it takes
big jobs little jobs small jobs not
shopping not eating at restaurants
selling the car like whatever i've got
to do right
it's a much different way of looking at
it then well i make this much here and i
also
i make this much here i'm tired all that
makes sense and i'd be this i do the
same thing we do with speaking gigs
right we do some gigs here and they
offer x and some offer y
if they just offered y that's fantastic
but if i compare it to x it feels like
man i'm getting ripped off i'm not
getting ripped off at all it's all a
blessing right
it's just it just depends on what i'm
what my goal is at the end of the day
does that make sense
completely i think
yeah thank you very much i needed that
sort of reiteration because that's what
i've been thinking and unfortunately i
share things with people and like all of
my
um
friends and family they're all
incredibly normal and so they come at me
and they're like oh no you know just do
more massage or you know they don't
they're not actually helping because
they're just like oh just get another
credit card it's fine you'll be fine
right yeah yeah and they're incredibly
broke and they're incredibly exhausted
and their marriages are incredibly on
thin ice and all that yeah it's normal
yes yeah yeah
yeah so i would just plan out and if i'm
unicorn i'm like okay i have two years
two years
and if that means i'm gonna get more per
hour on
you know doing the massage versus the
dog washing that i'm gonna pick the
massage even if i feel like i'm getting
burned out like i'm gonna do what i can
to get the most money as possible as
quickly as possible
because we're running and if there's a
day that's down and i can get on an app
and walk a dog on rover i'm going to i'm
going to sign myself i'm going to do it
right like it's
you're kind of plugging in where you can
just like john is saying to get as much
as possible um and it's gonna be
exhausting and it's gonna be tiring and
you're gonna do things you're like i
hate this but it's also gonna motivate
you to be like i'm gonna do more of this
because i hate it because i hate this
debt so much and i'm so pissed at it and
i want it out i want it done
so let that be the motivator too and
it's not forever it's not forever that's
the other thing is you can go back and
enjoy life
remember this nicole i've got a lot of
friends who i love
like i love and i
i just love being around strange people
and fun people and bonkers like i've got
some of the greatest friends on planet
earth they would do whatever i mean they
would be here in a heartbeat to help me
but they don't get a vote on how i spend
my money they don't get a vote on how i
live my life or what i think peace looks
like there's a few people in my life
that i've given that vote to
and so you've got a group of people in
your life that you love that you care
about but they don't give good money
advice and they don't give good life
advice and they don't give good peace
advice so love them hang out with them
share a drink with them have some nachos
but they don't get to speak in your life
about money because you have hit the
road you are running as fast as you can
and in 18 24 months we're gonna be
completely done with this nonsense
whatever it takes
and then you are going to be free and
then you're going to be explaining to
them what financial peace actually feels
like
[Music]
[Music]
triple eight eight two five five two two
five this is the ramsey show let's go
out to eric in philadelphia what's up
eric
hi how are you outstanding brother how
are you john and rachel great good my
question is i have uh
a car that broke down recently
and uh i
um don't have cash i'm really like on
baby step one
i don't have the cash to fix it um
and uh they said the transmission and
the engine both need to be replaced and
be like nine thousand dollars whoa that
sounds like a dead car my brother
yes
so uh i have two options uh one would be
to
lease something because my credit is
pretty good
um
i've been uh
putting things um trying to put money
aside but i've been paying down my debt
all along keeping the car going but now
it's like it might be too expensive so
should i finance something
or
should i leave something for like under
100 bucks a month
or
or
option three finance something uh oh
there's an option three there could be
an option three okay there's a bunch of
other options lots of options here okay
so
remind me you what do you have saved in
the bank right now
uh zero i'm like on baby step one trying
to get uh you're trying two thousand
dollar point you're trying to get to the
thousand dollar point okay but you're
still you're you're saying you're paying
down debt or do you mean you are just
paying minimum payments and staying
current
yes that's correct okay so you're
staying current on everything um
and when you do your budget
at the end of the month
you have
nothing is that what you're saying
basically like every every dollar has
been working
i make about 75 000 a year and i work a
lot of overtime what's what's happening
then because yeah there's a there's a
gap between what you're making and what
you have every month
where is it going oh well i'm about i'm
about a hundred
uh about 102 000 in debt
what kind of debt um
uh credit cards
uh student loans
um
uh
personal loans
those sorts of things okay and that's
what they told and i'm on a budget
and so i've been trying to figure out
unfortunately my wife
isn't on board with me
but i've been doing this for
a little over a year now and uh trying
to get ahead stay afloat
um
but unfortunately and i've i've also put
a little bit of money into the car
along the way well well you had uh you
had to do that hold on eric hold on
you were trying to
you're trying to drive a race car with
the parking brake on
okay okay you're trying hard i could
hear it man you don't you sound you
sound tired
are you tired
yes i am you sound not even tired you
sound exhausted exhausted because your
wife won't get on board with you
exhausted because you got all this debt
and you can't breathe exhausted that you
are working way too hard to be this
broke
and there's that embarrassment how old
are you
well i said before yeah there's that
moment when you think like dude i make
75 000 plus overtime
and i
literally can't go get a car
is that where this is right you feel
that shame that's just piling up around
you know what i mean
yes
are you
like rachel's going to walk you through
this but you got to say dude i'm ready
just to do it completely different
are you there yet because if not man
you're just going to tread water and
you're just going to keep treading water
and it's going to you're going to look
up and you're going to owe 130 000 and
you're going to owe 150 000
well i'm
pushing forward trying not to do that
but i'm doing a lot of it on my own
because my wife's not on board why would
she be on board with you
um
she thinks that i should uh
just make more money and that's okay
so and i've been
pressing along to uh uh try to to win
her over try to get her to understand
but
um
she just won't so does she does she work
yes she does
we make roughly about the same amount so
you have a total household income of
gosh 150 175 000
uh
yes probably more like 200.
man you realize like
you realize you could be debt free in 18
months
yes
if i can get her on board yes i do okay
have you gone to her
here's what we hear a lot you can tell
me if i'm wrong we hear people say um
hey honey i've got this plan
that we can get out of debt
and then they call and wonder why that
didn't work
have you sat down with your wife and
taken her out to dinner or i love going
to breakfast because the sun's shining
it's in the morning have you sat down
and said honey i'm scared to death and i
can't do this anymore
i'm scared that we are one heart attack
one twisted ankle one knee injury one
one
car issue one car issue
and if we will just change our life for
18 months we're talking about the back
half of our lives being a totally
different experience
have you sat down with her that way
no i have not um
get her to go out with me but uh
i have not but if i could get out or go
out with me and uh and do this it would
probably uh
she may consider it but i think she
believes that um
uh
you shouldn't have to sacrifice you
should you know um she's sacrificing her
husband you can't keep doing this my
brother you're about to die
you're you're one of the guys that their
wife calls in because their husband just
dropped dead from a heart attack because
he couldn't he had an elephant on his
chest for 15 20 30 40 years
right
right
you are you are swimming as hard as
michael phelps man and you're going
nowhere because you've you're
you're attached to the buoy in the
middle of the lake man
so you you said you think you can get
your wife to go out with you
yeah i think i can try you don't think
she'll just go to dinner with you
if she won't go to dinner with you you
got bigger marriage issues my man
yeah that might be the case yeah and
that's eric i mean that that's what we
find so much is that
when you get down to it and realizing
okay so why is this not working it's
like okay well there's another person
part of the equation that's not
working the plan so you're digging out a
hole and the bottom keeps sinking in
lower and lower and lower and so it's
just like it's not it really i mean i
don't want to sound hopeless for you but
it really really is hard for this plan
to work it's impossible both people are
on board and you're experiencing it like
you're telling us that and we're we're
hearing it and so
um
and so out of that even listening to you
talk about your wife and stuff i'm like
that money is just a tool right the end
game of life is not just to go and just
pile up a bunch of money that's not the
that's something but what money does in
our life affects everything
when it's not handled properly it
affects us
emotionally it affects us relationally
it affects our mental health it affects
our sleep at night it affects
so much
when it's handled the right way and
seeing
okay this can actually like amplify our
lives we can actually give to other
people that need it we can save it for
our future we can do all of these things
and we're going to use it as a tool
to create a life that that we want like
that that's what it's there for
and so that's what i would say is now
starting to expose even you and your
wife because you guys aren't even you
aren't dreaming together you're not
looking at the future together we're not
even eating together my man yeah so that
so i eric before before the money stuff
is solved um
that the marriage stuff needs to be
talked about too so i think yeah this
one's hard moments yeah do you want to
stay married
y'all are there
if you're if you're wondering if you can
talk her into going to dinner with you
or going to breakfast with you
there are way bigger issues than your
money right now
how long have you all been married well
i should put that on hold uh 20 some odd
years
uh um no you shouldn't put on hold on
because we actually find too that when
you start working together financially
it actually helps your marriage right
because you're working on a common
mission to get actually start to say oh
wow we're communicating for the first
time in two decades about
my fears and about my dreams and what i
want to do and and what where i want to
go on vacation like it starts opening up
these conversations so you can actually
use money as a pathway to start
communicating in your marriage again so
that's where i would start eric but to
answer your original question of why you
called in because you don't have a car
no we would not lease a car i would not
go into more debts no no no if that
means you guys having one car for three
months until you put some cash away and
sell stuff work extra just
uber wherever you got to go the next
month i don't care give up two grand and
go buy a beater if you have to like that
that's what it is do not go into more
debt eric this has to stop at some point
this has to stop at some point and it
needs to be now and you and your wife uh
get together you go i mean god man go to
therapy yeah today
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
with the rising cost of
everything these days a lot of people
are worried if they're going to just
have enough money in their bank account
to get through the month
but the good news is no matter where you
are with money today and no matter the
state of the economy you can
get on a path to build wealth and at our
building wealth live events you're gonna
learn simple common sense principles
around building real lasting wealth so
our building wealth tour it's been
blowing up you guys
i mean it's amazing there's two nights
that are already completed antonio's
gone out they were like down to six
tickets yesterday oh really so they may
be sold out okay so don't wait get your
tickets now so we have um so phoenix
september 13th is sold out so we added
an additional ninth so phoenix september
12th the night before will be there uh
and it was like it was over half sold i
think close to
three fourths sold so make sure phoenix
said if you want tickets to that it's
coming up actually this event will be
here in a few weeks uh so get tickets
there sacramento november 1st oh it sold
out minneapolis november 10th there's
some tickets left san antonio november
15th there might be might be tickets
left right now not sure so make sure to
check that out if you're in that area
um tickets start at 25
you can also get a four pack at sixty
dollars so go to ramseysolutions.com
events
to reserve your seat today these are fun
events we we did a few last spring the
first one so um so yeah we're ready to
get back on the road you guys hang out
with y'all all over and what's fun too
is these events even if you're not in
the city people travel to these cities
and make like a weekend trip and you
know they go to the events and i was
stunned how many people drove for three
four hours just to come spend the night
and it was it was awesome it was a blast
so come come check us out again ramsay
solutions.com events all right hey check
this out before we take the next call um
this was enough of a
that it made
the the news okay this article here from
this extraordinary actress tiffany
haddish
um
from today today.com
drumroll please
tiffany haddish revealed in a recent
interview that she used the entirety of
her girls trip check which is name of a
movie
to finish paying off her house
noting that she still suffers from broke
ptsd and rachel you and i talk all the
time about
your body takes
it pays the price for debt and we don't
think about that but your brain knows
if you don't decide if you don't get to
decide what you do tomorrow but toyota
motor company does or bank of america
does or citibank does your body knows
we're not safe we're not safe we're not
safe we're not safe
and so much so that when she grew up
she has some really strong imprints of i
will never be broke again and so people
give her a lot of a lot of they give her
a lot of hassle for you paid your house
off it's so dumb you could have invested
you could have no now i have a surplus
of money she writes but i'm still afraid
of being poor again
and so she used a final check to fully
pay off her home from the money she
earned
and i love this
she knows now
that no matter what happens in the
acting world if there's another shutdown
for a few years there's another this she
never gets cast in the role
i've got a place to live yep i'm safe
and her shoulders are going to drop
she's going to breathe differently she's
going to treat people differently and
here's what's cool she's going to
negotiate differently too when they come
and say hey we'd like you to take this
job for a million bucks
she's not going to take it because she's
desperate she's going to say i'll do it
for two
and um because i don't need your money
yes i have a home that's paid off right
i'm so excited i'm proud of tiffany
congratulations and i love this message
making the popular culture
hey a whale a way to participate in
being mentally well
is don't owe anybody anything yep live a
life a life where you are chained to as
few things as possible and that's
allowing your body to feel freedom i
love it it's amazing and it's so
fascinating too when you
talk to people that came i'm not sure
her specific story but if you came from
extreme poverty
there is that p there is this thing of
like okay i'm going to cushion myself
more than the average person because i
am never going to go back there like you
and i both grew up like that and both of
us have emergency funds
right yeah so it's wired in there
there's something about it it's just
like i don't want i don't want that i
don't want to repeat that
uh so i will do what i have to do and
even if people think i'm crazy but pay
off my house
so i have nothing uh but i love it i
know you know what acting job she's
gonna take next whichever one she wants
yeah she done anything she's good yeah i
gotta pay for a house i love it way to
go tiffany it's incredible all right
let's go to heidi in columbus hey heidi
what's up
hi dr john rachel thanks for taking my
call you got it what's up so i have a
question um the show that you did dr
john about the gas lighting i literally
listened to it and then i ran it down to
my husband and i said you have to listen
to this because
honestly it was it helped me finally
figure out the relationship problems i
have with my family um i came from a
family that honestly they gaslighted me
like everything i wanted to do they
always put me down
and now that i'm a mom of three
they're still doing it and it's to the
point where i don't know as a mom
i feel like i have to defend my kids um
and it's it's putting a whole strain on
the relationship now my husband and i
are great he's my biggest supporter
helping me through it
we live a couple hours away they came
down to visit last week and the kids
were so afraid this the older two are
six and four and they're like we can't
have our hair and not look good because
they'll they'll tell us it doesn't look
good
if i don't have my shirt not wrinkled
they're gonna pick on me and
it's and they see all these comments and
i'm just sort of at the point of i
trying to set boundaries but every time
i do they just
they start screaming at us they're
yelling at us so i just don't know how
do i undo the past and then not have it
affect my kids
hey you can't undo the past the past has
happened there's a period at the end of
that sentence
and many people in your situation you
are a professional peacekeeper and you
probably have been since you were a
little girl
your job was to make sure everybody else
didn't set off
and so you
developed a superpower of taking your
feelings and shoving them as far down as
possible and when you do that you
internalize their feelings and you
become the regulator for their feelings
and any negative feelings they have they
blame it on you am i right
oh yeah okay
so
there is no unwinding that that happened
there's a period at the end of that
sentence and any amount of energy you
spend trying to go edit that sentence
that's already been written is is energy
you're taking away from your husband
energy you're taking away from your kids
and energy you're taking away from
yourself it's a waste of time don't do
it
what i want you to do is to take the
word family off for a second
and i want you to think of a neighbor
who just walked by your house every
morning and then came into your home
to inspect the clothing and haircuts of
you and your kids
how long would you put up with that
not one time no yeah exactly one time
you call the police your husband
probably go to jail right and you'd have
to figure it out
your family
is hurting your children
your family's hurting you
your family's hurting your marriage
there's no negotiating with this it ends
today
and when you put a boundary you haven't
been putting up boundaries you've been
putting up like mean thoughts
because you've just been thinking mean
things you have imaginary conversations
with them in the shower right where i'm
gonna tell them and you never actually
do
right or you hint around it am i right
oh yeah yes
it stops today and here's what a
boundary is
you're not welcome in my home anymore or
hey we're all coming down this weekend
no thank you we already have family
plans
um
we'll we'll holler back at you
i don't owe you an explanation
i don't owe you a why and when they
start yelling at you here's the coolest
thing um it's not on every phone but my
phone has this feature called
off i just hang it up
can i ask a question you can okay if
she's never communicated i'm assuming
that heidi so correct me if i'm wrong
but if she's never communicated you
can't talk to us that way would you give
them a chat would you would you have a
conversation and say here's here's the
boundary
here are the comments and be very
specific these types of comments and
more anything along these lines
and if you
cross that boundary and you say that
you're never welcome like
for my dad and your dad my mom and your
mom yes
because i believe that my mom and my dad
and your mom and your dad
truly love us
and they often give us advice
that's their way of telling us they love
us
tell me if i'm wrong here heidi but this
sounds like
your family's predatory
yeah yeah okay they don't although
suddenly they don't want to hear if
there's anything wrong it's always like
well that's your fault okay okay my
animals are totally different story you
could sit them down and they would want
to make that change okay
there you go so sorry
it's hard you're gonna have to grieve it
because this isn't what you wanted you
wanted grandkids and grandparents and
christmases
and it's not gonna happen
so be sad be real sad grieve the heck
out of it and protect your heart and
your kids and your marriage
[Music]
[Music]
today's scripture of the day is second
corinthians 5 17.
therefore if anyone is in christ he's a
new creation
the oldest passed away behold the new
has come
stephen covey says be patient with
yourself
self-growth is tender it's holy ground
and there's no greater investment
rachel i love that um something i've
started
it hit me six or seven months ago
um
i often make life change into moral and
character issues like you better do this
or you're the worst or you suck at this
and i started realizing it you know what
most people
don't have a set of tools in their tool
kit like it's a set of skills and so i'm
gonna practice no i don't know how to
talk to my wife after we have two kids
because i've never done this before so
i'm gonna practice and i'm gonna ask for
your forgiveness and i'm gonna say i i
didn't say that one right the same way
as if i'm trying to learn how to do
drywall and it hang it sideways a little
bit right i'm gonna practice it next
time i know i'm gonna adjust a little
bit better
but i think that if
we stop talking to ourselves
in ways that we would never let somebody
else
talk to one of our friends
and we started giving ourselves some
great saying i'm gonna practice this i'm
gonna actually show up and keep trying
to keep trying to keep trying
um
i think there'd be a lot more peace in
our homes and in our hearts and in our
neighborhoods and in our country i
really believe that yeah it's just that
and i love that idea of just practice
it's like
i'm trying this out i'm not good at it
i'm going to stumble my way through it
so give me grace in it and when the
other person extends that oh man it's
everything so it's on both ends right
extending grace to people yeah when
necessary and
and then i i just imagine you can tell
me like imagine being a wife um and
like we'll just use winston for example
um because let's be honest he's like one
of the worst guys anybody smack right
but if winston was the guy who came home
and just had three or four beers and
watched netflix and played the
occasional video game and told the kids
to keep it down whatever
and then one day he came in and said i
don't
i'm choosing to be miserable and i'm
choosing for us to not have our best
marriage
i want to try something different and
i'm going to have to practice coming
home and i'm not going to say it right
would you do this with me i mean i gotta
imagine that would just be a wife would
yes yeah yeah i mean i
think that'd be amazing but it takes
humility to do that right it does it
does or it does take humility but also
takes looking in the mirror and saying
okay i'm trying to hang this drywall
this way doesn't work and the walls keep
falling yeah yeah why don't i just try
something else all right once i try
something different yeah um i remember
dave and i talked about
when he
you know he's three or four years out of
bankruptcy and
um that's when you know you'd pay the
piper on your marriage and he talked
about him and sharon saying we're
getting real close and they wouldn't got
a marriage counselor and i said that's
that was rare in the 80s for some for a
guy to have the courage to go to
marriage counselor and he said there's a
set of skills i didn't have i need to
learn something new and that's the
person who knows how to teach me those
skills and i thought man if everybody
had that attitude it'd be be a different
world but yeah yeah
all right let's go to uh carol in
wisconsin what's up carol
hi it's a pleasure to talk to you guys
it's a pleasure to talk to you what's up
um i had mentioned to my 16 year old
niece um if she'd ever thought about
opening opening an ira for well
my sister told me that i
um
to mind my own business and i crossed
the line
i agree carol what in the world are you
trying to do
corrupting your knees with those oh
how dare you aunt carol
right
why did why did she say he crossed the
line
um she thought it was her and her
husband's business to take care of her
financial
business
did which all's relationship in general
like what's your relationship to your to
your sister and to your niece or your
brother whichever one um are y'all close
are y'all like
all that organization
so i'm trying to think of my sister if
my sister
it's not like you yeah i just had the
sex talk with the kid or something
yeah it's like if my sister was like all
right to my 12 year old listen you don't
want to you want to go liquor than beer
not beer than liquor right so we're
going to take some shots and we're going
to yes i would say you overstepped your
bounds but if my sister was like hey
here's how i do money here's a 401k and
it disagrees with how i do it i would
say hey thank you for loving my son
and b hey hank this is how we do it in
our house right yeah yeah i don't know
i'm sorry kevin it's probably more of
her stuff than that it's like it's more
her issues she's she's i don't know what
she's feeling john tell her tell her
what it is all i can think of is if you
know
that your sister and her husband
are
are in debt to their eyeballs and are
stressed all the time and you went
behind their back and knowingly
said hey hey
i got a better way of doing it then
that's overstepping your balance because
your it wasn't about a money thing it
was about you kind of flexing as a sub
parent and that's that's that's never
cool if that's what you did then yeah
your sister's right but if you just were
trying to be loving and thought hey have
you ever thought about putting money in
the ira
i don't know i would call my sister and
i would take her to lunch and just say
hey we got we got bigger fish to fry
what's what's going on
which one was
um
i'm not really sure like
i don't know where she's coming from or
what she is feeling so yeah i think the
best path forward is to call your sister
and say hey sis what's going on
and just rachel just so you know just as
my friend
if you ever see one of my kids hank and
josephine you can be like pull them
aside and be like hey you should put
your money in an ira one day
feel free to do so i'm sorry carol carol
i'm sorry i don't yeah it's a little
bizarre to me i
are they do they struggle financially
the parents
um they're really quiet about their
financial matters so i'm not really
so you may have hit a hot button yeah
yeah there may have been something that
like maybe they struggle you know
whatever it is or they they they thought
they'd be further ahead financially and
they're not and she's questioning are we
doing this right are we okay
and by you suggesting something to the
niece could make them feel like well
gosh i'm not getting it right and i'm
going to screw up my daughter and here's
and i you know they're grasping for
control or whatever it may be they're so
dare you there's more issues i'd say
more of her issues than what you did
yeah what you did was not wrong unless
it was option one like johnson here's
how to appreciate being sneaky and like
hey here's how to approach it hey you
don't seem like you're doing okay are
you okay because i love you you're my
sister and i clearly made you upset and
i'm so sorry for for for making you sad
um what's going on and i'd start there
yeah all right let's go to uh making you
sad i thought you're not i thought your
whole thing is like you don't make
people with your kids
don't okay i'm sorry i made you sad
but you can't make someone sad they
choose to be sad right
i agree with that yes is that true yes
but
um
yes you're correct
um but if i sat down with you and said
i'm sorry that i did a thing and you
chose to get mad about it
that's not gonna go well so yes it is
semantics you're right but it is
semantics okay yes
yes
you're right um nobody has the power to
make you sad we accept that right we we
choose to be sad but in everyday
conversation you don't have to use that
like i wouldn't i wouldn't there
wouldn't be a way i would start an
apology it's scary when people take your
advice isn't it john yeah it's really
great
rachel the literalist that's the one
piece you picked up on it is i was like
i can't believe he's telling her
something that's not true
[Laughter]
there you go america sorry i'm making
this up as i go
way to go way to go rachel
um all right well now we're gonna yeah
we got time let's go
in cincinnati we're right up against the
clock get straight to your question
what's
up hey guys so i'm saving up about a
thousand dollars a month right now and
come due next year i should have enough
money for a 30 to 40 down payment on my
house excellent now the smart thing that
thanks now the smart thing to do would
be to take a thousand dollars and throw
it all at my mortgage but would it be
okay or why to take a part of that uh
thousand dollars and save it aside for a
really big toy namely a convertible ford
mustang
do you have another car
yeah you're gonna be on baby steps four
or five and six at that point so we
always say you can kind of let the foot
off gas go on a good vacation you could
upgrade your car i mean having an extra
car around
you could i would not i wouldn't spend a
ton of money on it yeah how much how
much would it be
no more than eighteen thousand dollars
i'm buying used of course the nineteen
so how much yeah here's what i would
tell you i wouldn't but i think we don't
have a problem with it it's not a huge
deal yeah i wouldn't but
knock your lights out just make sure you
put
20 down on your on your home yeah he
said yeah 30 which is great you should
you're doing great jd hey thank you
america for being with us today we will
see you soon right here on the ramsay
show
[Music]
hey it's john deloney co-host of the
ramsay show did you know over 18 million
people listen to the ramsay show every
week a lot of those people listen on one
of our 600 plus radio stations across
the country to find a station near you
go to ramseysolutions.com
[Music]
you